I charged Queen Elsa of arendelle with
treason and sentence her to death we
know a trickster when we see one and
Prince Hans has villain written all over
his face but according to a certain
frozen actor the Prince of the Southern
Isles might redeem himself in frozen to
is Ana's ex-fiance as evil as we think
keep watching to find out if only there
was someone out there who loved you we
thought we had Prince Hans all figured
out but now we're not so sure when we
first met him in frozen we thought he
was honest soul mate we mean they
finished each other's sandwiches for
crying out loud but it didn't take long
for Hans to show his true colors
he desperately tried to get rid of Anna
and Elsa and he nearly succeeded
luckily true love was able to swoop in
and save the day the last time we saw
Hans he was being thrown into his cell
and shipped back to the Southern Isles
his twelve older brothers were supposed
to determine his punishment and we
finally got to see what this was in
frozen fever
honda's brothers sentence him to cleanup
manure from the Royal stables so if
living in dirty lifestyle was what Hans
wanted he sure got what he asked for
still many fans believe that Hans is a
misunderstood character who was acting
out of desperation
during Hans and Ana's duet love is an
open door the ex soul mates talks about
their upbringing it's here that we find
out that growing up with twelve older
brothers was no joke twelve older
brothers three of them pretended I was
invisible literally and he also states
that he has been searching for his own
place for his entire life
being picked on and growing up without
friends is still the perfect recipe for
a villain still it's possible that Hans
feels bad about what he did to Elsa and
Anna
after all shoveling manure every single
day will give you time to think about
your actions but then again it also
gives you plenty of time to plan your
great escape Disney movies don't have a
shortage of Easter eggs so fans couldn't
help but notice Honda's pictures posted
up at a police station in big hero 6
does this mean that Hans escaped from
the Southern Isles and is asked to seek
revenge on Elsa and Anna we'll explore
that theory at the end of this video
first let's find out of Hans is going
redeem himself and frozen to during an
interview actor Santino Fontana spills
some behind-the-scenes secrets back in
2014
Santino hinted at a possible frozen
sequel which turned out to be true
Honda's voice actor also revealed that
the frozen writers weren't finished with
Hans just yet in fact they were even
thinking about redeeming his character
but what could Hans possibly do to right
his wrongs after all Hans as crimes are
super serious so clearing his name won't
be an easy thing to do he would
literally have to risk his own life for
Elsa's or on us to redeem himself and he
might just get that chance
what if Hans chooses to join Anna and
Elsa's quest and frozen to in the
trailer we see anna take kristoff sword
and swing it something behind her could
she be swinging at Hans it's possible
that the Prince of the Southern Isles is
following the group to their destination
but why would he do that let's look at
the possibilities Honda's either trying
to clear his name and right his wrongs
or he's up to no good
and since he's clearly good at acting
like a nice guy it's hard to know for
sure whatever is happening to arendelle
could be happening to the Southern Isles
so perhaps Hans will run into the gang
while attempting to save his people that
would explain why we see Anna swinging a
sword in the trailer after all she did
knock Hans out the last time she saw him
the only frozen heart around here is
yours so imagine what she would do to
him if they cross paths again if our
heroes and Hans have the same end goal
in mind
they might potentially band together to
defeat their common enemy after all the
enemy of your enemy is your friend right
we have a confession to make
we totally loved Hans before he became a
wannabe throw robber and how would we
not he was charming and kind and he took
super good care of arendelle while Elsa
and Anna were away sure he turned out to
be the villain of the story but the
prince did have his moments he handed
out warm blankets to families during
Elsa's snowstorm and he stopped his
henchmen from firing an arrow at Elsa in
her ice castle so there has to be a
shred of decency in there somewhere
still there are reasons to believe that
Hans is plotting his revenge after all
he has been reported missing
since his initial sentence we previously
mentioned that a most wanted poster with
Honda's face on it was posted up at a
police station in big hero 6 so at first
we were led to believe that Hans had
escaped from the Southern Isles and was
looking for a new throne to steal
however big hero 6 came out in 2014 and
frozen fever was released in 2015
so the timeline just doesn't add up the
only explanation is that Hans was on the
most wanted list before he ever came to
arendelle if this is the case then we're
not exactly sure that he's looking to
redeem himself everyone deserves a
second chance
but it looks like this isn't Honda's
first time at the rodeo
so what could Hans be up to we can tell
from the frozen to trailer that Kristoff
Anna and Elsa are embarking on an epic
journey and it appears that they're
going to be traveling far from home so
who's taking care of arendelle it's no
secret that Hans wants to be king so
maybe he'll try to take over errand out
Turin Elsa's absence or maybe there's
more to Hans than meets the eye there's
also the possibility that Hans will
pretend to have changed only to lure the
sisters away from arendelle
in the end Hans has a reputation for
being two-faced so he could try to lead
the sisters into a trap but his first
mistake would be forgetting who he's up
against honza's return has yet to be
announced by Disney or posted on frozen
twos IMDB page however it wouldn't be
their first time that Disney withheld
information to surprise their viewers
and besides we still don't know who
actors Evan Rachel Wood and sterling K
Brown will be playing in the sequel so
it's anyone's game right now whether
Hans redeems himself or adds a few more
crimes to his record remains to be seen
but either way we're excited to see if
his character pops up in the sequel do
you guys think Hans will appear in the
sequel let us know in the comment
section below and be sure to tell us if
you think Hans will turn out to be a
villain or a hero give this video a big
thumbs up if you're excited for frozen
too and don't forget to subscribe to the
things for more videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows thanks for
watching we'll catch you later
[Music]